Incapaces de fabricar sus propias toxinas,
estas hembras recurren a beber la sangre
de otras luciérnagas para conseguir sus sustancias protectoras.
Se trata de una luciérnaga vampiro,
creada por la selección natural.
Aún tenemos mucho que aprender de las luciérnagas,
pero puede que muchas historias se queden sin contar
porque en todo el mundo, las poblaciones de luciérnagas
están emitiendo luces de emergencia.
El mayor culpable: la pérdida de su hábitat.
Casi por todas partes, los campos y los bosques,
los manglares y las praderas que las luciérnagas necesitan para sobrevivir,
están dando paso al desarrollo y la expansión urbanística.
Y he aquí otro problema: hemos conquistado la oscuridad,
pero en el proceso, producimos tanta luz adicional en la noche
que perturbamos la vida de otras criaturas,
y las luciérnagas son especialmente sensibles a la contaminación lumínica
porque oscurece las señales
que ellas usan para encontrar a sus parejas.
¿Necesitamos realmente a las luciérnagas?
Después de todo, no son más que una parte diminuta
de la biodiversidad terrestre.
Aunque cada vez que una especie desaparece,
es como apagar una habitación llena de velas
una a una.
Puede ser que no lo notemos
cuando las primeras llamas se apaguen,
pero al final, estaremos sentados en la oscuridad.
Ya que estamos trabajando juntos para construir el futuro del planeta,
confío en que encontremos la forma
de mantener estas luces encendidas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)